[Music]
mindy
why are you naked why are you in the
girls it's co-ed here here fine take my
towel that is so much worse don't drop
it on the floor
pick it up it's my favorite towel
mindy i think we have a little problem
[Music]
sorry sorry sorry sorry i'm sorry why
did you wear a watch to a steering wheel
this is a 35 watch i'm not going to
leave it in the locker room oh god just
turn just turn oh my god oh my god don't
use me for leverage
nothing this is nothing
oh
[Music]
hey betsy i'm on a very private phone
call for 10 minutes don't interrupt me
[Music]
oh hello cliff
won't you join me in the hot tub no
problem i'll just be in the nude screw
you danny
[Music]
oh god
what's going on
the bird
what the hell was that close the door
look at you close the door that was you
on the inside what do you want me to do
get out get out do you want me out of
the the office or the building in
general because you just got to be clear
at me right now get out of here and
close the door
behind you okay i'm going i'm not
looking i'm a gentleman i'm going great
thank you if i catch the bird you want
me to bring it back i'm going to kill
you okay
having seen everything i think there's a
couple things you can work on i'd like
to point out you okay we'll talk
i'm happy that you feel enough of a
personal relationship with me that you
could open up about that
what i didn't i didn't open up to you
about anything
so i don't feel a personal relationship
to you okay
we just
just finished the exam
what's next
the breast exam my friend
all right
i've never had a gynecologist examine my
face before i'm just being thorough yeah
yeah if you feel uncomfortable with any
of this we can stop at any time are you
kidding me i'm fine sure absolutely fine
okay
my breasts
yeah go nuts
i will
okay
hey hey eyes down here
shut up okay just come on shut up don't
do that to me what am i doing i'm sorry
it's just you were doing a good job
does everything feel normal
yes it feels
feels fine you know what
after you finish this
yeah
main event i can't okay okay i i can't
do this you're being ridiculous i
thought you thought of me as a lamp why
don't you just examine my wires i'm
going home okay i'm going home
everyone
everyone listen up i am sorry to
announce that danny castellano was
unable to finish my gynecological exam
because of his personal feelings for me
which got in the way
dr castellano is that true i'm not
coming in tomorrow danny danny you may
take the day off but our friendship
endureth taking the week off see ya
danny you're fine you're just you're
being very dramatic i'm dramatic
you tried to shut down the m m store
because you thought the brown lady
eminem stole your looks you know what
i'm
hey hey hey come on you're doing this
the best thing you can do right now is
to go there look christina in the eye
and show her that this does not bother
you yeah yeah and it shouldn't bother
you we're doctors we can handle nudity
oh my god this is horrible we shouldn't
have come okay stop you said we're
adults we can handle it i can see every
hair follicle oh man this is a good it's
a nightmare i feel i have one but it's
still funny
wow this this is what makes you laugh
look i don't know what to tell you man
there's nothing funnier than penises i
can't even get through saying my name
without laughing are you asking my name
what's your name
stop it dude stop it ask me
come on
why must everything be settled by
tussling oh my god i'm tamara you look
like christy brinkley i know morgan god
these photos they're scandalous ray ron
took a picture of me in a bikini once i
was so mad but then he sent it to this
modeling agency and now i'm on shampoo
bottles in japan
holy christmas
i don't know personally i want a guy so
rich he could just let himself go but
not so fat where he has to get cut out
the house dr c is a masterpiece again
though i just want me a rich fatty you
know like those cats with the cigars his
skin is so taut i just want to know it
guys i'm so sorry if they see this
you okay
you look good for an old-ass man
i'm in my 30s i'm not gonna get up again
so you can walk the aisles you're not
gonna get thrombosis i don't care what
the today show says i don't care it's
not that i want to apologize
it took a lot for you to make peace with
your dad i mean you did it in a
completely melodramatic way i could have
done without wandering around the desert
i sat in an armadillo killed it that was
not good for my self-esteem but
you're not mean
you're great
hey
look and i'm sorry about what i said
about cliff you weren't lucky to be with
him he was lucky to be with you
that letter going
can i read you the first part sure
dear cliff i'm so sorry for what i did
it's just that casey and i had a sexual
chemistry yeah that wouldn't happen no
that's that's not good okay can i help
you okay okay
how about something like this dear cliff
please forgive me
i'm sorry i was so stupid and reckless
with your heart oh my god okay keep it
coming little shakespeare okay you know
you're right for someone when they force
you to be the best version of yourself
that's how i know we're right for each
other cliff this is amazing
all right here goes nothing
and
[Music]
dear cliff please forgive me
i'm so sorry i was stupid and reckless
with your heart
[Music]
um
hello morgan
i thought about it i need to get mindy
back
yeah you do
who am i speaking to it's cliff
you tap that cliff
you tamp that into the sunset
[Music]
i would
hello
hey i really appreciate this thank you
so much and as payment one tonic water
thanks i will be right back
oh brother
hey
hey danny all these waters look the same
i i just don't
[Music]
what why did i have to run here i got
very sweaty on the way over here come
here okay
it's just a normal day for me like every
other day to eat my lunch at my desk
catch up on some pornography what when i
came across this
wait you should not be
does that make you dude good
oh my god i don't think i'll ever be
able to have sex with another guy oh my
god that's exactly what you say in the
video okay that's really good
mindy what on earth were you thinking
making a sex tape don't you know that
means that creeps like me are gonna
watch it oh my god peter
please promise me that you have not
gratified yourself while you were
watching this oh my god no i didn't
peter can you please be more convincing
than that just don't look off guiltily
look me in the eye and tell me you
didn't do it i didn't oh god oh god look
i know this is bad for the whole
practice
i gotta say i've never met a real
pornography actor up close and personal
kind of geeking out i can't i need to
lie on the floor can i ask you a
question
now what was with that trumpet music
that was just my next-door neighbor
practicing his trumpet
it's actually kind of beautiful if you
listen to it there was a very spirited
debate about that in the comment section
the comment section
well yeah it's a video online okay
verified user bro bgyn says hey i work
with her
i told you it was geeking out i gave it
three stars
you